SETH VARGO: All right.
Welcome back.
Today I have Sandeep with me.
Sandeep is a Developer Advocate.
What does a Developer
Advocate do?
SANDEEP PARIKH: Yes, so
Developer Advocates at Google,
and I think at a
lot of other places,
are engineers who get to
engage with the community.
So they get to participate
by speaking at conferences,
writing cool documentation, code
samples, basically giving back.
And also learning
from the community,
like developers and
operators, and using
that to improve products.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So they're not like
marketing people?
SANDEEP PARIKH: No.
They're very much intended
to be like engineers
who have come from that
ecosystem or that environment.
So former developers, operators.
Specifically within
Kubernetes, like definitely
cluster operators,
sysadmins, DevOps,
those kinds of folks with
that kind of background.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
So what exactly does
a Developer Advocate
do in the Kubernetes ecosystem?
What kind of things
are you involved in?
SANDEEP PARIKH: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So the name is sort
of funny, because I
think Developer Advocate
implies developer only,
when really, within the
Kubernetes ecosystem,
it's developer, DevOps, pure
ops, and kind of further
and further down the stack.
So within the
Kubernetes ecosystem,
I think people are getting
to participate by one,
helping build better
code samples around just
using Kubernetes for operators.
But also going
further and further
up the stack with new
projects and tools
that are very developer-centric.
Which Kubernetes by itself is
not a developer-facing tool
in a lot of ways.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
So walk me through an
average day for you.
SANDEEP PARIKH:
Yeah, so a lot of it
really is, well, one, nonstop
email checking and group chat
participation.
And then filing bug
reports on products
that are part of Google
Cloud, writing code samples,
writing documentation,
updating code samples
and documentation, because those
get out of date very quickly.
And answering PRs on GitHub
and helping merge in new code.
SETH VARGO: So I'm sure
everyone is dying to know,
how many Slack channels
are you a part of?
SANDEEP PARIKH: That's a number
I will never share publicly
because it would frighten
and confuse most people.
SETH VARGO: So you said you
work a lot with the ecosystem.
What are some really exciting
ecosystem tools and kind
of patterns that are
emerging that you're
excited about, personally?
SANDEEP PARIKH: Yeah, no.
I mean, I think
what's really cool is,
I was at the first
KubeCon back in 2015,
when it was 300 people in
one room in the Palace Hotel.
And it's grown incredibly
since that time,
in the last three and 1/2 years.
And what's really cool is, it's
gone further and further up.
So we're getting
closer and closer
to like end
application developers.
So I'm really excited
about the things
that make application
developers' lives easier.
So some of the really cool
tools-- and a little bit
self-serving, because
they're Google tools
that we're working on-- but
I think Scaffold and Jib
are really cool tools.
And then something
like Knative, which
isn't exactly
developer-facing, but it's
a project which is going to
make it easier for application
developers to get a lot
of these full benefits
without having to
write YAML and remember
v1beta1 or v1alpha1 APIs.
SETH VARGO: Exactly.
So let's say I'm new to the
Kubernetes community, right?
You said 300.
We're at like, what, 8,000
people at this conference?
The community is
growing dramatically.
If I'm new to this
thing, where do I start?
Where are some areas that I
can make an impact, maybe even
if I don't have a background in
software or computer science?
SANDEEP PARIKH: Yeah,
you know, everybody
has a unique experience to
bring, which is what I found.
And just hearing talks from
across the community today,
and in the last couple
of days at KubeCon,
everybody's got something
compelling to share.
I think there's tons of getting
started resources out there.
But there's never
enough applied use case.
So taking the experience
that you've had,
even if it was without
Kubernetes, and saying, well,
how would I map that to
a Kubernetes environment
or an environment with Istio or
with any of the other thousands
of tools that are out there?
You know, rethinking
through that
and then sharing that story
is still pretty valuable,
because I think it helps
everybody try to map something
new in their brain.
I just went to a session that
was about PCI compliance,
right?
So processing credit card data--
something we've
been doing for years
in traditional environments,
but not as much in Kubernetes.
And that's really valuable
for the community to learn.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
So share stories.
SANDEEP PARIKH: Yeah, exactly.
Share stories.
And it doesn't have to be code.
It doesn't have to be
an innovative thing.
It just has to be
something that's, I think,
positive in helping move
the community forward.
And that could just
be a simple thing
that you've learned
that you want to share.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Well, thank you, Sandeep.
SANDEEP PARIKH: All right.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]